So recently I had a client of mine
ringing me up
and she was in a really
tricky situation.
Her and her boyfriend of three years
have basically just broken up.
Now, they live
in the same flat together
and they've got five months
left on the contract.
So not only are they going
to have to share the flat
for another five months,
but because it's a one bed flat,
they're going to have to share
the same bed.
Can you even imagine
how difficult that must be?
I remember helping one couple
in particular whose communication
had become so toxic, that they could
no longer hear and understand
what the other was asking.
All they heard were
their worst fears.
Let's face it,
breaking up is never easy.
But when you're in a situation that
forces you to get on with an ex,
it can be a really difficult
divide to cross.
People fall madly in love
and in my experience,
they fall madly out of love as well.
You might find yourself
in a tricky situation
if you live in the same halls
as your ex at university
or you go to a party
or a wedding of a mutual friend
or you happen to work together.
Often the people I help
share children and assets.
And although you may not
like them at the moment,
your ex is likely to be
your best possible resource
to help you look after your children
and create the life
that you want for yourself.
A messy breakup means that
you need to find creative ways
to cross the divide.
I know it's not always possible
but really try to give one another
proper space after the breakup.
Ideally commit to going around six
months to one year of no contact,
just so that you give yourselves
the chance to get each other
out of your systems.
Take advice from all sources -
Accountants, tax advisors,
benefit officers -
whatever is going
to help you the most.
If you have an area
that you're afraid of,
if you're afraid of finances...
get help.
Don’t ignore it or stick your head in
the sand and hope it will go away,
it won't.
Embrace it and grow.
When you do see your ex
in a social situation,
go out of your way to take the high
road, however difficult that may be.
Say hello, be graceful, be mature.
So I was in a situation like this
myself a few years ago.
I had been asked to do
a speech at a festival
about a book that I'd written,
now this book was mainly
about a really painful breakup
that I'd had with an ex.
And my new boyfriend of a year
had come to watch me do this talk.
And as the workshop started,
in walks my ex, from the book,
with his new girlfriend.
And look, this could have been
such an awkward situation
for my new boyfriend, but as soon
as the workshop was over,
he went right up to my ex,
introduced himself
and they ended up really,
really getting on.
So much so, that he
has very recently asked my ex
to be an usher at our
wedding next year.
Get in touch with the new you
and who you want to be.
Think about where you might
want to be in a year's time.
Be curious about those options,
think about your wider context.
Get back in touch with your passions,
your friends
and the person that you may have
compromised in the relationship.
Focus on the future and the person
you want to be,
rather than the painful events
that may have taken place.
Whatever you do,
do not put your mutual friends
in an awkward position by making
them choose between you and your ex
or talking really negatively about
your ex behind their back.
Trust me, this does not
put you in a good light.
Mentalise and empathise
with your ex-partner's needs
and try to be objective.
It takes a great deal
of emotional effort
to see your ex through that lens.
But remember you did love them once,
and you did see their
positive attributes.
They still have them,
you just can't see them right now.
Thanks for watching! :)
If you liked this vide hit like and subscribe!
Click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you soon!